Fade in.
Laurie Atkin.
She was the first.
Honored with a Scientific
and Technical Award
in 1961 for her
work at Technicolor,
Laurie was a scientist, artist,
a storyteller, a glass ceiling
breaker.
Cut to 2021, and Laurie's
pioneering legacy
has become an expanding
story of women shattering
what is possible in the science
and technology of filmmaking.
This year, Hayley Iben of Pixar
Animation Studios, Kelly Ward
Hammel and Maryann Simmons of
Walt Disney Animation Studios,
will be the recipients
of the 24th 25th and 26th
Science and Technical
Award presented
to women by the Academy.
Hayley, Kelly, and Maryann are
honored for their innovations
in hair simulation.
And this year marks
the most women
honored at a single Scientific
and Technical Awards.
Is there work to be done?
More barriers to break?
More progress to be made?
Yes, of course.
But the story of women
innovators making movie magic,
their story isn't ready to
fade out, not even close.
Today more than ever, cinema
storytelling is science.
Cinema storytelling
is technology.
And women are helping to
redefine science and technology
in the movies.
And that means a
brave, bold future
without limits for each
and every storyteller.